the Illinois State Senate facing
backlash for requesting a whopping forty
1.6 billion dollar federal bailout as
the state's financial troubles continue
to grow amid the corona virus outbreak
the Chicago Tribune editorial board
calling the request shameless and
dishonest our next guest agrees say
liberal policies are ruining his state
joining us now is America first national
spokesperson Steve Cortes Steve thank
you so much for joining us
this really is grotesque for the for the
Illinois State Senate to request 41
billion dollars from US federal
taxpayers to bail them out not just for
coronavirus but for a whole lot more
right well you know shameless really is
that the watchword here unfortunately
and the politicians that are ruining
this city of Chicago in the state of
Illinois they believe that in this
crisis in this moment of crisis they
found a beard a way to mask what has
been a financial disaster in this state
included in that 40 billion Jason they
asked for 10 billion dollars just to
bail out our unfunded pension
obligations now those existed of course
well before the virus ever hit anywhere
in the United States including Illinois
here's the real issue
it's the spending by the state of
Illinois particularly when it comes to
employees and pension obligations right
now in Illinois
according to open the books we have one
hundred and nine thousand public
employees or retirees who are making
$100,000 plus in this state and Jason to
give you one particularly egregious
example in Park Forest Illinois which is
where I grew up my hometown it's a
blue-collar suburb of Chicago the just
retired superintendent of elementary
schools there Joyce carmine she made
$400,000 in her final year she will make
$300,000 for the rest of her life and
this in a community a blue-collar
community where the average home price
is only seventy five thousand dollars so
that kind of reckless spending is what
has made Illinois into America's grease
with all of the debt and all the
financial woes but without the sunshine
and the islands unfortunately Jason well
look here's what the Chicago Tribune
said and I quote it is not surprising in
Illinois politician finally put
in writing what economists and financial
watchdogs have been warning for years
that elected officials who failed to
take serious seriously decades of fiscal
warning bells in the state eventually
would seek a bailout from the federal
government what is beyond galling is
using the coronavirus as an excuse and I
got to tell you when I was in Congress a
few years we highlighted this because
unfortunately it's not just Illinois
yeah places like Phoenix Arizona
California New Jersey whoo you're right
it's a multi trillion dollar problem
where they promised all of these
retirement benefits but they haven't got
the money to ordered to actually pay
them right and Jason look I think it's
clear that these Democrat led states
they are banking on they are hoping for
a federal bailout they believe that if
Donald Trump were to lose in November
which is not going to happen but they
believe that if that were to happen if
they could potentially flip the Senate
that the federal government would
effectively federalize all of these
problems from these profligate blue
states well look none of that is going
to happen what will happen it should
happen is what speaker issues me up
what leader McConnell said when he
articulated that we really do need to
change federal laws and federal policies
to allow bankruptcy for states like
Illinois that's the only reasonable
solution well they're gonna have to deal
with it because it is a multi trillion
dollar problem the federal government
can just print money but states counties
state and cities they can't Steve thank
you with so much for your expertise and
joining us early this morning we do
appreciate it
thank you